let's do the exercises this way let's
think about like three minutes on a
problem and then we ask people to their
ideas because I advise you to discuss it
with your neighbor
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh non-negative reals so every team is a
function of one variable in non-negative
yes
[Music]
[Applause]
twice
so any idea for exercise one if you
haven't seen it before
okay you look at the product okay that's
good one plus yeah and then what
this is real stable so this part is good
but one - is the I times Z and then
differentiate with respect to Z 1 - is
the I square do me there's the right
time some other is right and then the
derivative over Z K times yeah and then
you set it at 0 I think it easier thing
would be just to do this
G + di yeah you do this and it
differentiate TK times and then evaluate
it at 0 then you're looking at the
coefficient of e to the K so you choose
every n - K subsets of the eyes will be
one monomial of this - yeah okay I guess
yeah n minus K if you differentiate
that's one way it is another way you
start from z1 up to the end this is real
stable now you apply partial Z 1 up to
partials the end first of all this is a
stability preserver operator because
again you can just plug it in in that
tier and it would have minus W 1 all the
way to minus W and that's real stable so
this is this is this is a directional
derivative and in fact more generally
you can see any directional derivative
pointing to the positive or st. is the
stability preserver operator so this is
a stability preserver operator if you
apply it once you get elementary
symmetric polynomial and minus 1
variables like this is equal to
basically valuation of all s in n choose
n minus 1 of 0 applied again you get the
limited symmetric polynomial of like n
minus 2 and so on and so so if you apply
it basically n minus K times
both of these are using tools of
integration proved even we didn't prove
the bourgeois brand material derivative
being okay the relative being estimated
preserver is not so hard to prove you
can okay let me say that you can you can
if you want to differentiate with
respect to Z one you can set set Z two
up to the end like the safe setting to C
2 up to CN for these guys having
positive imaginary values then then you
get a univariate polynomial of z1 you
look at the roots of this I know that
this cannot have any root in the
positive in the upper half complex plane
otherwise this would have been for these
guys so if it has a root in the positive
complex plane
upper half of the complex plane the
original polynomial P is not real stable
ok so so so so for the original
polynomial P the roots of these are not
in the upper half complex plane they're
in the you know below it now when you
differentiate by Gauss Lucas theorem the
root should be in the convex hull of the
roots of the original state now because
the roots of the original thing are not
in the upper half complex plane even in
the convex convex all of them there is
no point in of
it's the general statement for the
second solution for any positive
direction you can different yes exactly
so if you have anything like this
summation of I partial Zi for AI is not
negative this is a stability preserver
operator you can also add it by you can
add some real numbers we also can plug
in the same
so let's go to exercise to say this I
don't know the symbol what I'm saying is
that whatever symbol is it's the
products or the symbols or each variant
yeah I don't want you to use that I know
but I don't want it to use the food
that's a that's the easiest easier proof
against but now so yeah the more strong
you have the stronger theorem then then
you can you know it's the symbol of the
product of symbols is straightforward
right what else can it be power is
greater than one one at a time right
once you know this argument then you
actually just chant this element
reorganize do that naturally in the
symbol you just have to prove for for a
very birth of time and I don't even need
support no even better for one man at a
time with the version I said I know
there is I don't want the simple version
so but if you is the following that okay
[Applause]
now we know this is a staple and then we
want to argue that the polynomial be a
stable yeah and now suppose that this is
not real stable so so we have some r0z
once this is 0 so then just look at the
polo with the original so look at P 1
star then this is some product of
see one side
it is sufficient yes then we know that
okay so we know that the sum of what you
need C times 1 over C R will be minus ax
is our couch is depend upon oh not that
big I mean maybe so these
yes so this saya never did because if
they were fully different the original
polynomial would have a would have would
vanish at z2 society to start as wealthy
as time so then we would be done because
yes yes the original would be please
sorry 1 3 2 star and some of the stuff
is ago he should contradict to the race
hundreds of feet
it's basic would you repeat the
arguments for yourself okay okay so you
know that this is really stable
and we would like to prove that this is
very stable
it's factorizing the original polynomial
P in terms of the yeah yes you know
monomials depending on powers of Z is
not reactive so this would mean that
there is some and they all in the upper
half complex players I just keep the Z 2
Z gangsta and now pour this Greek a
polynomial in Z 1 yeah and those are the
roots yes and you're saying there must
be a rooted positive imaginary value you
know not by all of them must have make
it negative imaginary yes yes no is no
polynomial would be a ha yes so we have
this one but you can also compute this R
1 R 0 simply this is sum of 1 over C ax
that is mostly elevation of the yes yes
[Music]
point is that and then once we have this
then you can the objects into this you
can play the same game Johnny take the
same game that Johnny
just so first you fifty Jersey one
around negative one over Z one that you
just differentiate down to your
polynomial Z or Z one similar to that
when you prove Newton I did okay let me
the interest of time just they say a
quick proof we're running out of time so
I had this quick proof in mind so you
you do you take the product of one minus
partial Z one partial of Z prime one hey
V prime one partial of three water I'm
going to add a new variable Z prime 1
which is it sort of dummy copy of z1 and
they apply this operator one glass of
that plus of that so one plus of that if
you plug it in this operator is a
stability preserver operator and we're
gonna get 1 1 minus z1 like V prime 1 W
1 so that's a stability preserver so
this is a stability preserver operator
so evaluate I apply this and evaluated
at V 1 equals 0 this way you basically
killed every monomial of z1 which has
degree higher than 1 or every
epic monomial of z1 which has degree
higher than one in z1 and you can
replace the one with the primer later on
we can we can just rename the prime 1 to
be 0
[Music]
let me okay let me okay just taking
minutes and this basically how you prove
it so basically okay so there are two
parts there's a part a to prove that f
is a lot concave polynomial and the
proof of that is simple basically
because F is really rooted and has no
negative coefficients you can write f as
the product of T plus alpha eyes for
alpha is non-negative you speak this
because really that follow even up with
no negative coefficients must have
negative roots so you can write F this
way maybe there is some still area but
okay this is really matter so f is like
this
now log of F is just summation of log of
T plus alpha and this is a concave
function so the sum of concave function
is concave so this is contained
so this says that log of F is concave in
fact more generally any realistic
polynomial is a lot concave function
over the positive or cent but here I'm
just talking about the univariate case
of the log of f is concave now that I
can use the following I can say log of f
of T is less than or equal to log of F
at zero plus T times the derivative of
log of
[Music]
here all I'm using is that if you have a
concave function you wanna you you take
you take the tangent line at zero let's
say this line that the function is below
the tangent line that exactly gives you
this inequality so because because log
of f is concave it's below the tangent
line and that's a tangent line at zero
so we just just now plug it in so okay
so so now you get that from this you get
that log of f of T is we now divided by
T log of f of T over T is less than or
equal to log of f of zero plus x now
what is the derivative of log it's F
prime of zero over F of zero and then
because I divided by okay I'm taking off
log T from left hand side I also take
off a lot different right now okay now
okay now I get so remember that I'm
looking at the infimum of F of 0 or F of
T over T less looking at the infimum of
F of T over T so I get to choose T okay
so I basically choose T to be the
minimize therefore the right hand side
we can differentiate and find out the
value of T but know I've done my
exercise that the minimizing is to let T
to be F of 0 over F prime of 0 let's
plug that particular T's let's call this
T star as follows that log of f of T
star over T star is less than or equal
to log of F of 0 plus now I have T star
and T star is F of 0 where F prime of 0
I'm multiplying my F prime of 0 over F
of 0 so this is plus 1 and then I get
minus log of T star which is minus log
of F of 0 over F prime of 0
now this log of F of 0 cancels out with
this log of F of 0 so the right-hand
side is equal to 1 plus log of F prime
of C now you raise both sides to the
power of E you get you get f of T star /
t star times 1 over e is less than or
equal to F Prime
a female in particular is also facing
you need to think you need oh yeah Lou
tenders and a negative coefficient if
you didn't have not gonna get coach
coach to do something work as well yeah
well it's proof is a stronger yeah so
here okay I didn't say a few things good
with proof actually gets the like random
Vardhan conjecture like it gets n to the
N over N factorial here I'm getting
something simpler everybody it's a
quicker proof
[Music]
[Applause]